every time i take my eagle out i get
butterflies in my stomach
it's this dichotomy between a heavy bird
on your fist that just instantly becomes
lighter than air
you get to cultivate a really unique
relationship
there are very few people flying eagles
in the united states and of that only a
handful of women but my very good friend
jamaica is beginning her journey into
eagle falconry
the ability to be mentored by a woman i
thought that that was
something unique that i shouldn't pass
up that opportunity
[Music]
falconry is the ancient art and
tradition of using a trained bird of
prey to hunt its natural quarry in the
wild
i spent a lot of time in mongolia
apprenticing under kazakh eagle hunters
when i started i felt pretty out of
place
because i didn't have that hunting
experience and i was a girl it made me
really fortify my passion and persevere
because it was hard in the beginning
i've admired her from the very beginning
her journey into falconry was different
than most
the gumption she had as a teenager to go
to mongolia and learn about eagle
falconry that's a rare thing
[Music]
hey boy
a little over a year ago i got a call
from a friend who had found an eagle
standing in the road about a mile from
my house it was
close to death
so i took it to the vet that afternoon
and participated in in rescuing that
eagle
falconry is pretty much the only way at
this point that we know for sure allows
that eagle a reasonable chance at
survival by helping them
through that period where they're
learning how to catch things
i made it my life's mission to get an
eagle permit and acquire an eagle
through an established rehab program
that works with falconers
there's a lot of knowledge involved in
falconry there's also a lot of ways to
do it wrong it's really not necessarily
instinctive i would not want to get into
eagle falconry without a good mentor to
contact
knowing that lauren was available to be
a mentor to me was a huge part of being
willing to make that decision
to get inside the mind of an eagle the
first time is a it can be a difficult
experience
[Music]
you just have to find your bearings and
understand where an eagle's coming from
in order to create a good fit confident
hunting eagle so essentially that's what
i'm helping jamaica do when you find
someone that has that passion and is
willing to share it with you it's it's
really a special thing
the bond that you develop with someone
who gives of you their time the way that
lauren is giving to me will be something
i'll treasure forever and hopefully
someday i'll pass that on to somebody
else
you